hot  [Music]  but they've already thought out the  problems they know what's going on  the heads are air cooled and then with  the body we basically have a sort of  waistcoat with rubber tubing running all  through it so basically we pump cool  water around martin's body and because  we've made this enormous suit we've had  to make chairs for him to sit on which  are like very big giant director's  chairs  [Music]  we have to make sure that pathways are  clear that he can get through doorways  so you need a team of people supporting  him the whole time  you have a couple of dressers who get  him into the bodysuit  you have an animatronic engineer who  connects up all the wiring and the  electronics  and then operates the radio control  which moves the eyes moves the mouth  it's known as team hagrid and we've been  working with these guys now for 10 years  and  you make very very strong friendships  there